join now from Kiev by velodimir Aria for
Ukrainian MP for the European solidarity
party hello to you thank you for joining
us on the program this morning what can
you tell us about the strikes of
yesterday and this morning
oh we have an ongoing alarm rate sorry
now and uh the latest news that one more
power plant were hit by a Russian
missile in Vinita region so uh there are
Russian policy is ongoing and yesterday
uh attack uh we understand that it was
planned in advance
Putin would like to have represented
like a response uh to the uh explosion
on the Crimea breach but it hasn't been
proven uh who stays behind uh that
attack but for putting it makes no a
reason to find a truth about to use a
reason
for escalation in Ukraine uh the reason
for that for me is pretty understandable
uh in one month uh Putin is going in to
the meeting of G20 countries on Bali
Island in Indonesia so he would like to
present him not a weak leader after
defeats of Russian army uh in uh
conventional it's a conventional battle
uh grounds but he would like to speak to
the world uh from the position of
strength so that's why he changed the
commander on uh operation against
Ukraine and ah his first day was an
airstrike to scare with the attention to
scary grain of course ukrainians were
not scared but starts more donate to
support uh Ukrainian Army but at the
second uh we understand that next month
we could
be faced to the attention of new offense
from the north with the participation of
Belarus as well as president lukashenko
he yesterday claimed that he would like
to join uh and support Russia in uh the
uh as as an ally of uh Belarus uh and uh
the the this means that
Russia Russian plan has clearly seen to
uh divert Ukrainian forces from the
offense on East and on the east and
south uh and start to uh to defend much
more North uh Direction uh Ukrainian
strategies military strategies see what
the Putin wants very clear and we are
really ready to all our kind of attacks
that we are facing to but at the same
time we need a bit more help uh to meet
our got a new wave of Russian aggression
okay
what are you going to do then to
retaliate we've seen these images
yesterday we know that there have been
more strikes as I was saying in
zapparitzia overnight how will you
retaliate to these attacks
well we need uh of course to
strength the Ukrainian air defense
systems and uh yesterday American
President Joe Biden and German
government promised to supply Ukraine
with
the modern ones but at the at the same
time uh what we are really vitally need
now while our Ukrainian energy systems
are under operation as well as strikes
where not only to power plants but on
also for the case system
ground system places
so uh I do believe that in this case
European uh Union uh could be a good
could help us with the supply and uh
electric energy as well as our systems
uh Ukrainian and EU are united to
survive as well as many regions now has
no electricity and uh
this uh this situation we don't know how
long it could uh be taken
okay and we know that G7 leaders meeting
today G20 uh Summit uh later on in the
month in Indonesia
what's your message to those world
leaders
yesterday
um uh was under attack uh the Visa uh
the Visa uh Consular uh uh office of
German Embassy and uh the German Embassy
where 200 meters from the famous you
have seen the picture uh the uh missile
attack in this city center of uh Kia so
uh I would like to tell that if no are
serious and decisive uh steps uh we all
will be under attack
so now Ukraine is a playground uh a
bottle sorry Battleground for uh the
Democratic world and we understand that
uh without uh permanent and long-term
assistance uh to beat out Russian
aggression and to compel Russia even to
forget uh to uh attack other countries
and neighbors so we cannot survive and
it will be changed the world security
system so we cannot let it make real so
or to be United and decisive uh
this is the only way what we have to do
it's good to talk to you um do keep safe
thank you for taking the time thank you